Hey, good afternoon, evening.
Hello, Namit.
Good afternoon.
No, I'm sorry. It's morning for you right now, isn't it?
It's in fact midnight.
Hello, everyone. Ohh, I see that you guys already snuck the introduction in. Alright, alright, alright.
Namit.
Yeah.
Excellent!
No, no.
Not yet, Jose, not yet.
Noel, do I have time to go run and get my last cup of coffee for today?
Yeah, I know.
Dude, I'm more worried about the fact that you're having a cup of coffee about 3 hours before you go to bed.
Yeah.
Oh, don't worry, I'm a pro at this chief. No consider yourself.
All right.
And, by the way, Pritam, nice to meet you. I know we've kind of crossed in emails here, but I don't think we've actually formally met. So, my name is Navid Selimi on. I am the new director of our service desk here. I'm replacing Christian. Been with Data Prize for about...
OK.
12 years now, working out, you know, different positions within the service desk, and again, now stepping into fulfill Christian's previous role.
Thank you, thank you. Nice meeting you here, Namit. Again, my name is Pritam, one year less than you, 11 years with ID by design, and I currently manage the service delivery operations here from the Philippines location, where the entire enterprise team is.
Ha ha ha.
Yeah.
And yep, I'm the primary contact for anything related to operations, queries, questions, performance issues. So I work closely with Jose and William.
Yep, nice meeting you. So thank you, Jose, again for adding him here in this call, and we'll make sure that we'll keep you on emails moving forward.
Oh.
Thank you, please.
Afternoon, William, how are you?
Pretty good.
Yeah, yeah.
And I just want to make sure I'm pronouncing your name right, Pritam, correct? Okay.
Yeah, that's correct, Pritam.
Correct, if I ever get it wrong, please do correct me. I'm not great with names, but I do try.
Definitely.
Mmh.
I will just try and open. In the meantime, William, how is things going on?
Mm.
Oh, I would say...
So far, so good. I was out yesterday, so I feel like I'm still getting caught up on things, but I hear, I hear it was busy, but I hear it was manageable. Common, just looking at the queue today, number of tickets, but you know, it's Ivy, it's always the case, but it doesn't.
Doesn't seem like an overwhelming amount, so we're trucking along here.
Any improvements you have seen on the customer response ticket count or in progress ticket counts?
Oh, I will say I have seen, at least, I mean, fairly anecdotally, but I do, I feel like I've seen people getting to the, to specifically the tickets we wanted them to focus more on was tickets that users have replied to, just making sure that we're getting back to those folks.
Mhm.
Yeah.
in a timely fashion. I do see that that is occurring far more frequently now. So next battle is, we're just going to work on the ones that users don't reply to. So sometimes some of those tickets have a tendency to linger a bit.
Okay.
So, or things that don't have definitive, you know, things that are, I guess, less urgent items. You know, they're less urgent, so they get put on the back burner, but we still need to make sure we get back to them at some point. So things like that.
Okay, okay. No, thank you, William. Also, I have been connecting with the team and I think we are slowly getting into there. They are shaping up, they are getting comfortable with the tickets, the navigation and stuff like that.
And, uh, yes.
Talking about the new.
Okay, we'll talk about this things later. Jose, anything from your end? How are things going on? And thank you for the utilization report.
Okay, cool. Yeah, let's start with that.
You're scaring me now.
TA.
This thing's got a flair for the dramatic.
Where?
Yeah.
We have some challenges, Houston. Listen, so let's start with Carmina.
Mhm.
I don't know, don't know what's going on with Carmina, and then you know, let's start with.
A lot of refused calls.
She's having a lot of difficulties.
She's not putting any time into her tickets. As you can see from the utilization report, she has very little to no utilization for the amount of hours that she reports to work.
Um...
So, I'm not really sure what her struggles are.
But she's a really big concern of mine because she doesn't seem to be working out at all.
Mhm.
Because we've had many conversations for with her, even while she was in training, we had a lot of we we we had conversations with her and trying, you know, so at this point.
Really concerned with with with her, really concerned with Helen.
Um...
Like, I'm gonna be really nice 'cause my boss is here, but...
You know, okay, you know, I understand that she has problems with family, she's got some circumstances going on. But for her attendance is starting to be an issue.
And it's something that I mentioned from the beginning and it really hasn't changed much. I think you would agree with me on that.
Yep.
But my biggest concern with the team right now, because the indicators show that, for me anyways, like we could go over to refuse calls, we could go over how many calls they've taken, we could go over those metrics, that's all well and dandy. But the utilization report tells me.
what they've been doing in tickets, how much time they've been working on something and putting that into the ticket. So, you know.
If there's nothing in there and they come to work for 40 hours, just...
Using that generalization right, if you know where it.
Yep.
For 40 hours, but they only have 7 hours bill for the week. What did they do?
If they only have seven hours in the ticket, one ticket or whatever amount of tickets that only go up to seven hours.
That's concerning to me.
So those are the kind of things that I need to, I think that from where my service desk stands right now, ours, because I have like my my my my my team here.
Like those things that I just mentioned will go a long way in helping me clean up a lot of a lot of my problems.
I need bodies, I need them to be here, I need tickets worked on ASAP. You know, once they come to the service desk, once a ticket comes into the service desk, I need hands on it as soon as possible, regardless of the source.
And then we work to get it either to the next team that's going to resolve it or we resolve it. That's the nature of it. Pre time. Pretty much. That's it.
And by the way, I did ask on the media yesterday to get you access to our some of our resources, and we're working on, you know, on that.
Okay.
But yeah, that's my feedback.
We we have IV is has a really high mean time to engineer right now. I just came out of a meeting with the entire team where we discuss 18 tickets and the overall performance of the service desk from the from the week prior, and IV is still, you know.
Red, really good with full metrics though, to be clear. So the ASA is fantastic. We're doing a, you know, a good job at getting to the people, but we're for certain things, some things we're not doing that great, and that number is escalating.
Yeah.
Resolution times are really hot.
which is something that we've addressed.
in the past.
Okay, resolution time, Jose, let me...
check with the team that if they are getting stuck technically or process wise, because last time I circled back with them, they said they are struggling something with the process, not very much info is there, so they have to get back to the group, wait for it. So I will just cross verify.
the things with them, if it's still the process or it's a technical roadblock, because I don't find there should be a technical roadblock because I have went through their tickets, like not exactly each and every one, but few of them randomly.
These are basics.
I'll not say that I will need a proper, you know.
Okay.
L2 or L1 plus level of troubleshooting. Yeah, process is different, like creating a distribution list. They are not directly doing it via Active Directory. I think you guys have this GUI interface from where they are doing it and adding the group members and all. So which is kind of different. And from where they need to get the approvals and all and get.
Get those things done.
So I can work on the resolution thing and thank you so much for the phone answering thing. Because I see the entire team sitting on their desk. So that should not be an issue answering a phone call and that's what I am really good to hear. Talking about Carmina and Helen.
Yes.
It started, in fact, when you sent me the utilization report, I went through the entire report. I am good with the people, like those who have billables more than 25.
because I think they are working 7.5 hours and one hour break in a day.
But you have some engineers in here that are doing fantastic, Pritam, for example, Mister Mercado.
39.7 out in one of my reports here, this one is from 66. So, you know, and that just goes to show you, you know,
Yep.
That, that's what that's the expectation, and it can be met.
Yes.
I can see Krishna, 39, Rana, 35, Sarah, 35, Jane, 32, Kim, 31. So these guys are doing a fantastic job, I can see, because if I look at 7.5 in two
Yeah.
five days, the total billable hours is 37.5. Those one hour is their break, right? So out of 37.5, if they're meeting 39, 30 above, I think it's a good job. Improvements are there a little bit for Paula, Jaime.
And Zeus rest, I think, Nico.
I wouldn't worry about anybody, anybody, anybody. Pritam, I wouldn't worry about anybody except for Carmina at 10%.
Yes.
And Helen, like 31. To be honest, I'm like, seriously, don't even worry about the rest of the team. I'm comfortable with where they are. I've gone over the metrics. I've seen the numbers. I'm comfortable with where they are, and they'll continue to improve. Those 2 there, though, that's, I don't, it's a different story.
System.
Evening.
And that those numbers say it.
Ten percent.
I...
Ten percent, Pritam.
I had a word with like Michael, sorry, William, three, four weeks back, Emily also. And I think we agreed to give these guys, Kermina and Helen, especially like two to three weeks and see how it goes. I circled back to them this morning, like because yesterday I was kind of occupied, so I circled back to them this morning, especially Kermina because Helen is out of office.
on the numbers and they really don't have a good explanation, Jose. They really don't have, which I can present to you or if I'm not convinced, how can I present it to you?
Give me today's time; we'll schedule some time with Carmina and Helen tomorrow, if she comes in, then most probably we might take a hard decision.
S.
Yeah, I think that's how I feel. I think I would rather pretty much just not have them and start with new bodies that would be going to, you know, training rather than, I don't know how to correct. There is no correcting this in my opinion. This individual,
if things are not working out.
Yes.
Carmina, for example. Helen, I don't know, you know, what her issue is. She's got a lot of dependence.
Shows a lot of promise, but then she takes a lot of steps back, so, and, and at this point...
No, it makes sense, Jose. So just give me today's time. I will just have a word with them and I will drop you an email with detailed next step actions.
If.
But I'll ensure that the team is not impacted, especially the IV team. Helen Carmina, they are with work group 14, I believe.
Kurt.
No, they're Carmina's working with 12 and Helen is, yeah, Helen's tier 2. Oh, Helen is also, yeah.
Well.
Share desk.
Yeah.
Yeah, tier too.
Helen is with Angelica, I believe.
Yes.
And Julka Cruz, yeah, tier two. No, I can I can give you good replacements.
Yeah, but, and to be honest, they like tier 2 was transferred to a different team, but I'm only looking at their utilization report and I'm just looking out for data prize at this point. I really don't care who's addressing this and I'm gonna deal with it at this moment because, you know, to be honest, Pritam.
Do you think she's coming back?
The last email I have received is how mom's helped.
I don't know.
Two.
I can't be sure with you now, Jose, but she is keeping a constant communication. If someone is not coming back, then they will stop communicating.
That I can say to you.
Uh, just let me... I received the last message at what time?
At 1908, that's like 7, 8 A.m. Eastern Time.
OK, like when, like, from what all new onboardings, Pritam, like, there's two things we really do need to start stressing with them. Two things, and one I already mentioned, right? Well, I think I probably already mentioned both of these, but attendance is a is critical.
Seven 080 today.
It's critical. We're dealing with just the amount, the right amount of people that we need to get what we need to do that we promised our clients. So critical that we have people in those chairs. And then critical #2 is that they know what they're doing. So MS 365,
From some of the things that we noticed, you know, some of these engineers have been struggling with some of those basic...
Knowledge skills for Microsoft, and even though they, you know, they, they, I sat in on those interviews, so they did really, really well. I can't really say that we missed anything during the interviewing process that would have led to that, that would have indicated that they this would be happening.
So I just want to be extra careful moving forward with those areas. Scrutinize the heck out of them. If they haven't worked large MSPs, I probably wouldn't even.
You know, Pritam, that's been like part of the big issue with this team here, especially with Ivy, is that they've been, they were overwhelmed with everything, right? Processes, confidence, and volley to a certain extent. So.
No, IV, I believe IV is good now. I had a word with each one of them and I can see the confidence is good. It was the initial stage that they had some shaky start, but now I believe IV is settling down and it's good.
Helen and Carmina has been a challenge from day one. I want to be very transparent with you. I was talking with Emily and yeah, I know you and William don't have that visibility with this team, like Carmina, Helen and Angel, but I was talking with...
No, I do. I have visibility. I have visibility over everything.
Okay, you have, okay. So Emily, I was talking to Emily and I have receiving things. So I have been in constant talking, coaching with them, trying to make them a success, but it seems we have provided enough time now and investing so much of time does not make sense.
I could have easily get another resource up and running by this time. So I think it's time I have a word with them and see what best we can do. Don't worry, I will give you good resources now. Now I know. See, what happened when we started the enterprise here? I was not aware how we can go through the things. Now I am.
aware of it. I know what type of people you need, what type of expectation is there, so I know which people I have to place there.
So, yeah.
No, we're good. We're working things out. So we're doing pretty good. And I do feel that that's what I wanted to hear. I think that their time is up pretty much. I think that we've given them enough time. I think they've had more enough conversations for them to make the adjustments.
Yep.
they needed to make, raise their hands if they've had any issues and that's not happening. That's a really big concern. So yeah, do whatever you gotta do to let's get ready for them.
No.
Yeah, and a quick question here, Jose. Do we want to keep them till we get a replacement, like in next one, two weeks, or do you want to remove them with immediate effect?
Whatever we have to do.
Helen's not even coming to work.
So...
Yes.
Get me wrong.
That doesn't mean anything. I'm just saying she's spending it here.
Yeah, I know, I know, I understand, just...
Oh.
Helen, because of the reasons that she's put in there, not you, that's up to you, because it's neither here nor there, right? She's not here, she's not here. Carmina, she's here, it's up to you, right? She's getting paid and she's really not doing anything.
So...
She's getting paid and she's not doing it.
Is how I see.
I get your point. I get your point. So what I can do is, I can, I can end of this week, I can remove her and we can stop the billing and we can revise it. I can get it done for you.
Let me pull up real quick. Give me give me one second. Like this is from the prior week. I know that I Mondays are really busy and I end up being busy all day, but give me one second.
And it.
Chop.
Yeah, so okay, so this is for the week ending June 6th, Karmina, 10% at Helen, 30.
Helen had a 32% utilization, and that was with a...
On the full schedule, so she worked, she she put 11 hours total and tickets that day for a tier 2 engineer.
I really, I'm just stuck. I don't know what she did for the rest of the day, for the whole week. That's, that's, I don't even moving on. Let me.
Yeah, let me, I do want to chime in here. I think part of our frustration is in training, we noticed these same like behavior patterns with, you know, basically not billing time correctly. And Emily, when, you know, kind of asking them point blank, like, show me how to, you know, like, like, show me how to do it.
Uh-huh.
right? You know, she would have no problem doing it. It's just when she was left to her own devices, would proceed to not do it. So from our perspective, we're just having trouble understanding what the gap there is. If you know the expectation and you know how to do it, what's preventing you from billing your time?
Okay.
Correctly, because if she...
It just make, you know, either she's under-reporting and under-billing her time, which is a problem, or she's, you know, sitting idle, which is another problem, right? You know, but either way, it's just not a good look. So hopefully one that can be addressed, but we're also kind of at the...
Point where we feel like we've invested a lot of.
time in helping her understand what the correct process is and we're not necessarily seeing results.
Correct.
She, she, so for the week ending last week, or week ending the 13th, right, she did improve to 57% utilization. So from 10%, she went up to 57%, but her hours worked because she called out were 30 hours and she put in 50.
No, definitely.
Fifteen hours, so still significant, so, and this is what kills.
So, you know, just like what Javid just said, you know what to do.
Mhm.
You know what you're supposed to be doing, so what's the problem? Tier one, she's in one of my craziest work groups, 12, so I know there's sufficient work to go around to keep them busy throughout, you know, their entire shift, so there's still something wrong, and then going back to Helen on this one, she...
Backtracked, and this is my, my, you know, to prove my, my...
My point with her, she she she moves forward and then goes backwards, Helen.
You saw it where she was previous week, now she goes back to only available 7.82 hours out of a 32-hour work week if she also called out one day last week. So...
28% utilization.
Agreed, Jose. And like I said, it's time to take some hard decisions. Just give me end of business today. I will drop you an email with the next necessary steps. And sorry, William, you might have to invest some more time with me to get the replacement, guys.
Stop.
And I'll share some profiles with you, good ones, people who are accountable and who can work. And once I have those resume as profiles ready, I will share it across to you. And most probably by end of this week, Jose, I will pull these guys out of the account. I will suspend the billing so that you guys don't.
Yeah, no.
Yes.
keep on paying for these guys until we have the replacement candidates on boarded. And I will also see if I can help you out with some replacement rebates, like so that we don't have those time invested in training does not doubles up.
I.
I'll just work with my stakeholders on that.
All I heard was rebate and I like that. So...
Thank you for that, Pritam.
Ha ha.
Yeah.
No, it's one or the other thing, you know.
All right, so you touched on my next, you touched on my next topic, which is, you know, we have a couple of open records with you, don't we?
Yes, I have one L2 NOC and one HSS. So HSS means L1. L1 I will schedule it with William, the NOC L2, which Lindsay confirmed me day before yesterday.
Yeah.
Oh, we're not interested on the NOP one. Wait a second, you said L1? What do you mean by L1? Tier one?
No.
Yes, tier one, tier one.
Okay, all right. No, it's okay. Like, it happens to me all day. Different terms, and I'm like, let's focus here. Okay, so our tier one, do you have one only?
Sorry, my bad, my bad, here was.
I have one only. New requisition.
I was going to say we just got a we got a message from Lindsay saying there should be another one. It might be coming, to be fair. I don't know if it's fully three. I know it's been the the the records been approved on our side, but I don't know if that means that it's made it to you yet or not. But I just know right before this meeting, we got a message.
And it's for Will?
About that, so dude.
Should have like 2 at least from my side.
So those are all mine? Well, not yours, right?
Yeah, yeah, one of them was the one to replace Adrian Pasquale. That's been lingering for a while. And the other one, yeah, the other one's for Jay Salvador. I think that's a more recent one.
Yeah, like a year now.
That is more recent. That was the end of May. Okay. All right. So, or last week or so.
Okay, I have three in total, but I will just name them out. I don't know if this is what you're talking. First is system engineer to knock.
Not mine.
There is System Engineer 2 for NOC profile only. I have one Azure Cloud Engineer, Azure Cloud Engineer that's temporal, maybe 3 months. And then I have System Engineer that's tier one.
Yes, good with Helpdesk and Office 365 immediate. I have this three.
That's that sounds like the one for Adrian.
So, it sounds like we...
OK, so he still doesn't have Joseph.
Yeah.
This is the one, William, you gave me like a couple of weeks back when was I was following up with you.
Yeah, yeah, exactly, exactly. Yeah, that's the one for Adrian, yeah.
And for Ivy, you already made the replacements for Rodge and Jay and Dhiman.
So, some.
Okay.
Yes, Jaime, it's William. I've already picked up the guy for Rodge. I'm sourcing a couple of more candidates. So we'll give it to William as soon as we have them.
Oh, so we don't have a garage replacement yet.
Not yet.
Got you.
Mhm.
It's taking time; it's a lead position.
No, it's okay. I just, but I need to coordinate with the rest of the departments because the, you know, the team lead that we're backfilling with.
Yeah.
He's he belongs to other people now; he's not. I stole him for a little bit, but it's OK, alright.
Hahaha.
Um...
So I just don't want to give you people who are not good or suited for this role. So I'm looking for the best candidates who can replace Rodge. I don't want to repeat the Rodge story again.
Appreciate it.
Yeah, I do appreciate it. It's not the easiest rule, I will say. So I definitely would prefer it. If it takes a little time, I'd much rather get the right person personally.
Yeah.
Yeah, no, we learned our lessons, some lessons, and well, let's apply what we learn. All right, Javid, you said you had a couple of things for...
Yep.
Select.
Yeah.
Oh.
Otherwise, we can coordinate via email or something else. Let me know.
No, I think I just need access to ConnectWise just to look at the tickets. If not ConnectWise, I'm good with thread also because I will technically not work on tickets so that I can just have a monitoring at my end so that I can go ahead and work with the team in case that TL is absent.
Like Rodge was out of office yesterday, and William was also out of office yesterday, so I need my also view that, okay, if there is a customer response pending, I can talk to the team. Hey, can you, if someone is free, can you acknowledge this? Second, I need some access to the performance management, so that I myself can also see.
Rather than William coming to me or Jose coming to me that Carmina's utilization is 10%, I can proactively see it from my end and get it fixed before Jose comes and gives it back to me.
Okay.
That's why I ask.
Can I ask, do you have prior ConnectWise experience?
Yes, I do.
Okay, so what I'm kind of hearing from you, excuse me, I apologize, is access to the service reports, as well as access to the time entry reports, and then access to the service boards. Is that, is there anything that I'm missing?
Right.
Correct.
Noel.
Okay, cool. I'll submit the request. We have to get it approved, blah, blah, blah. But we'll get cracking on that for you, okay?
Okay, sure. Thank you. Thank you so much.
My pleasure. I did want to just end with really quickly that Pritam we appreciate your time. Thank you so much. I feel like we beat you up a little bit this meeting, but I want you to know that we very much value your partnership and your efforts here. I've heard nothing but great things about you from everybody that I've spoken to. So
Very much looking forward to, you know, you know, developing our relationship and, you know.
Definitely, definitely know it, and you know...
Please, I'm not gonna tell it, but don't rat me out then if he thinks I beat you up this time.
It's not like that. Okay. So data price is like one of the valued partnership that Javid really endorsed. Like Javid is my CTO. So I'm always on my toes when it comes to data price. And I have been working with a lot many enterprise and strategic partnership and that's why they have
Yeah.
put me from India to Philippines here.
So Javid is trusting on me and definitely I will go ahead and make sure that we go towards the right direction. And yes, initial hiccups were out there, but we'll definitely settle it down.
Thank you. I appreciate that.
Again, there again.
That again.
Nice meeting you, Javid, and thank you, Jose William, for all the inputs. Just wait till the end of the business, Jose. I will drop you an email with the next action steps.
Likewise.
Appreciate that. See you in two weeks, too.
Thank you.
Take care. Bye.
Bye.
All right. Take care, everybody.
Take your way.